breaking news Hunter Biden still not a
great guy not a great guy there is a
story that's that's being reported now
uh Hunter Biden
is trying to prevent his illegitimate
daughter from using the Biden family
name as her own name
uh the the girl's mother Hunter's baby
mama
uh Ms Roberts just asked the circuit
court judge Holly Meyer for her
daughter's last name to be changed to
Biden why would she want her daughter's
last name changed to Biden because she
says this this would allow her daughter
to quote benefit from carrying the Biden
family name Biden name is now synonymous
with being well educated successful
financially acute and politically
powerful
now some of those things are true I
don't think all of those things are true
well educated I don't know about that
certainly politically powerful certainly
successful
financially clever that's certainly true
Hunter Biden now going to court to try
to stop this
Hunter has denied that he's the father
of this child Hunter has tried not to
pay child support for the child Hunter
and his entire family have refused to
acknowledge the child Joe Biden won't
acknowledge his own granddaughter uh
Hunter then went back to court tried to
lower the child support payments that he
is required to make this Hunter Biden
who's selling his
hideous Modern Art canvases for half a
million dollars a piece and Hunter says
he can't pay the full child support that
he owes to his daughter and now he wants
to prevent her from taking his family
name
and the most Shameless part of Hunter's
latest
slight against his daughter
also happens probably to be the truest
which is that the argument that Hunter
Biden his lawyers are making in court in
court is that the girl should not take
the Biden family name because the Biden
family name is a disgrace
that's the actual argument Hunter's
lawyers are saying that if this little
girl takes the hunter Biden name she's
going to be attacked for it she's going
to be smeared in the Press then it's
gonna it's gonna make her life worse
and I don't think that that the argument
that Hunter's lawyers are making is the
actual reason that he's trying to
prevent her from taking the Biden name I
think the bidens are trying to keep her
from using the family name because that
would then if she used the name it would
require the Press
and everybody to acknowledge that she
actually is one of Joe Biden's
grandchildren and the family wants to do
whatever it can
to ignore this girl neglect this girl
not acknowledge that she exists Joe
Biden puts up stockings at the White
House for all of his grandchildren he
doesn't include this poor girl
could you imagine you're growing up your
grandfather's the president of the
United States and he refuses to
acknowledge that you even exist
could you imagine how that would make
you feel that's a really terrible thing
to do and and Joe Biden who sometimes
has a reputation it's always a nice guy
everybody likes Joe that's a really
cruel nasty thing to do to to your own
little grandchild so I think that's
that's why the Biden family is doing it
but the argument that they're making I
think accidentally happens to be correct
the Biden family name is an absolute
disgrace and they are a representative
of a whole modern liberal culture that
is shallow that is nasty that is that is
corrupt they they are a bye word for
that I agree if I were the girl I might
not want the name either probably want
the perks that go along with it and I'd
like the name to at least Force the
family to acknowledge my own existence
but but Hunter's lawyers accidentally
probably happen to be correct that that
Biden name sure is a disgrace here's the
headline
this is pretty bad this is pretty bad
it's gone viral
and I I have a take on it this is that
Today's show is going to be called
Michael's unpopular opinions but why not
that's what we're here I'm not here to
Pander to you okay I'm not here to
sugarcoat you and throw you only what
you want to hear I'm here to tell you
the hard truth as I see it so this is a
headline exclusive
Daily Mail husband of Tennessee cop
going wild Megan Hall
stands by his wife and tries to salvage
their marriage after she was fired for
having sordid sex romps with six
colleagues as she shrugs off the Scandal
and says it's time to move on
she's 26.
and her husband is 28.
and
she slept around with a lot of guys so
someone writes to me because I've spoken
on the show about how I don't think
divorce is good and should be avoided
pretty much at all costs though in
certain instances if a woman or her
children face the threat of violence say
a separation a physical separation might
be permitted or even even morally
required but divorce per
say is very bad I think
this is summer writes and says hey
Michael in the case of this article
going around about the woman who
cuckolded her husband six times with his
colleagues uh do you think that's
sufficient grounds for divorce
and the answer the real hard answer
strange as it may sound to our modern
culture
no
no that's not sufficient grounds for
divorce at least at least as far as I
see it
at least as far as the traditional
Christian teaching is the traditional
Christian teaching on divorce which is
still believed by the Catholic church
and many if not most Protestants and
Christians around the world is that
there is no good reason for a divorce
basically again it's certain limited
circumstances there could be an argument
for a kind of a separation and yeah I'm
not denying that
but that there is no good reason for a
divorce
and I'm not I'm I'm somewhat surprised
that people are so surprised by this
because this was
standard Christian teaching until
relatively recently
and relatively and when I say relatively
recently by the scope of Christianity I
mean recent the past few recent
centuries
some Protestants have argued that
divorce is good in certain cases or can
be permitted
but
I don't I don't really see why this is
so shocking it's kind of like when when
you bring up abortion
and people say well you oppose abortion
you say yes
say well do you oppose abortion what
about in the case of rape and incest
which is really the same thing right
we're talking about incest we're taught
almost always we're talking about rape
so what about in the case of rape and
you say well that's a very hard case I
agree I recognize accounts for way less
than one percent of the abortions that
happen every single year but uh my
premise is that human life has value
from the very beginning and it's wrong
to kill people and also killing your
baby is not going to make up for a
terrible crime that was committed
against you it's not going to make you
feel better it's probably going to make
you feel worse it's not going to bring
Justice to your rapist at all it's just
going to commit an injustice against a
little baby and so from my premise the
human life has value from the very
beginning I have to conclude that
abortion is not permissible period so
same thing here if you're arguing that
that marriage is the Perpetual Union of
a man and a woman for the good of the
spouses and the sake of the education
and generation of children
then
that then that's that if you if your
premise is that marriage is
indissoluable
meaning you know if you if you find out
that that the marriage was fraudulent in
some way that uh a husband was actually
hiding that he was previously married or
the spouses didn't mean their vows when
they said their vows or there was some
element of fraud you could have an
investigation that's called annulment
meaning the marriage was null from the
first place but if you really believe
that marriage is indissoluable what God
has joined let no man separate then you
just can't support divorce in in recent
centuries some Protestants have pointed
to the so-called exceptive clause in The
Gospel According to Saint Matthew which
says that uh except except for the case
of pornea which is sometimes translated
as adultery or an unchastity or other
things except for the case of that
divorce is no good and they say this
well this is an exception
this is a novel argument from the
perspective of historical Christianity
the line does not appear in the gospels
of Saint Mark and Saint Luke does not
appear in the writing of Saint Paul the
meaning of the word pornea is quite
controversial I don't think it means
what people say that it means I don't
find this argument particularly
persuasive but it's these hard cases
that really allow you to see your
premise
do in the case of abortion do you really
believe that life has value from the
very beginning
and that people are people no matter how
small and it's wrong to kill people okay
then you've got to stand firm on that
even in the hard cases do you really
believe you conservatives who say we I
support marriage I support Family Values
do you really believe that marriage is
indissoluble
even if look it's a Fallen World we all
make mistakes we've all had tough
situations happen to us I'm not shaming
anybody for being divorced half of
marriages end in divorce
but in the principle of the thing
do you do you really believe that well
if you really believe that
then this
cop was trying to work it out with his
wife who's
got problems
that cop is doing the right thing head
on over become a member right now use
code noltskin w-les dailywire.com
Knowles use code nulls at checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign
[Music]